I really think I'm
sorry hey Anthony what's up what check
email
okay second here guys that's how we
hacked a billionaire you remember that
email from Anthony yeah that was me how
is it you if it's from Anthony I had a
lookalike email address so it looked
like I was emailing from Anthony but I
was actually emailing as myself so how
do you get a you can just purchase it
it's doco instead of.com and then the
phone number I was spoofing that phone
call so I know but it was Anthony's
voice I used a voice changer that's
bananas isn't that the first thing that
we were able to steal see my driver's
license probably also recognize that I
was able to steal your passport Co card
pictures of your grandkids these
pictures were in your Cloud so any
website that you're currently logged
into we could access because you were
logged into your email on your machine
we were able to steal all your
emails